greetings from podcast Ville
it's Wednesday the 15th of July you
better pay your taxes [ __ ] the
church what's happening now is brought
to you by Express a VPN listen right now
we'll all living our lives on the
Internet
your kids got school on the iPad your
wife's got the in-laws on FaceTime and
you're just trying to watch the church
in mind your own business but now more
than ever you need to protect your
privacy online trust me you probably
think I'm why not just use a private
code because I think they break it to
you that's not gonna work no matter how
many times you erase your history people
can still see every site give it a visit
so will expressvpn what I do online is
nobody's business to protect your online
activity today with VPN that I trust to
secure my flight button privacy right
now the church family can go to
expressvpn doc calm slash Church to get
three extra months free on a one-year
package that's Express VPN dot-com slash
Church listen your anonymous get an IP
address that can't be tracked today go
to expressvpn comm slash church and get
an extra three months free on a one-year
package that's expressvpn kick this
[ __ ] melee
James welcome to church
[Music]
Oh
Wednesday [ __ ] we're here we're
queer yeah I'm saying what do you want
from me
things are bad all over thank you for
watching me on the fight companion we
had a great time fights were great the
whole [ __ ] thing it was great to see
Joe you know it's tough right now
because we don't see I haven't seen Theo
since February I haven't seen Tom
I saw sicko one time I haven't seen
anybody I see Lee I see Steve Simone you
know but I didn't want you guys to think
we don't see anybody you know I haven't
seen the lies I haven't seen you know
Ali Wong I don't know what these people
doing I try to check with him with as
many as I can but uh it's overwhelming
what's going on right in that way I know
that Texas is on fire Arizona is on fire
Florida is on fire my heart goes out to
you you know we're on fire we'll
probably be on level one by Thursday
that's a reality by tomorrow we'll be on
level one I mean that could be a reality
so uh sings the looking bleak out here
today you know I go for my little
afternoon ride I do a bunch of [ __ ] and
I'm wanting to stay busy and then I come
over here I checked the office make sure
the gate is closed and I went after to
the main street here my kitchen and I
was telling me I had to tell you guys
I'm parked at the light I'm minding my
own business
it's maybe two to 45 I'm sitting there
at the light
I'm the second car behind the car and
all of a sudden I don't because I'm
headed towards like you know there's a
train station there that's always been a
little bit on the [ __ ] evil side you
know exactly every transition every
chance this one is not bueno
they sell tamales you should blood for a
week the white the pork had splinters in
it but kind of [ __ ] pork as winters
it
it's a shady [ __ ] place I used to
walk my wife down when she worked
downtown I would walk her every morning
because it was that shady you know and
I'm watching Adam I let my left eye I'm
seeing a commotion guys and next thing
you know I see a guy go down
just go down like four BAM he fell from
the sidewalk to the street and he was
opening onto his head then I lay a guy a
lady was waiting for the bus but she was
looking towards me she didn't see it
coming
and he clocked her in the head with his
shot axe with no accent adjust the
handle he clocked her in the head but he
clocked another dude on the RHIB that
guy went down and then he started to
proceed to hit this guy and this guy ran
away from him now the light turns green
we're about to move and this guy runs
across the street and the guy with the
axe handles chasing them across the
street and they go into the train center
they're sprinting so I make a [ __ ]
u-turn you know me I'm Batman I'm gonna
intercept this guy in it with the car
this is my excuse right here there's my
big chance to shine right there's one of
those you gotta hit those guys were
[ __ ] and I just run him over with the
Subaru at this point I'll be in the
paper tomorrow Joey Diaz is a hero he
saves the light him at the door yeah I
was gonna hit him with something so I
made a u-turn and I cut down the [ __ ]
alley because he was running down the
train Street right then what did he look
like what did the guy with the axe
little white 5 foot 8 homeless or no he
looked a little homeless he looked at
homeless yeah like a leather vest on I
take the Warriors they're not I haven't
watched it yet so he had like a little
leather vest on and like brown pants and
I [ __ ] when he hit him he chubby guy
ran first then the guy ran after him
with the axe and security guys ran after
him we're [ __ ] walkie-talkies what
good are they gonna do yeah
dad chased him so I make the u-turn I
shoot down the [ __ ] thing I'm driving
the same way he's going I'm triggering
I'm gonna [ __ ] meet him right there
but he runs the other way now he doesn't
have the ax handle no more and when I
went to look he's the guy that he was
chasing was on the floor there was blood
all over his [ __ ] head I was on the
floor already he must had him two or
three times at the accent but he dropped
the ax handle so the fingerprints are on
it so he ran down I chased them
but he made a left into the [ __ ] bus
terminal like he he went around the
corner right back towards the Train like
they weren't gonna see him this guy's
nuts but this is happening you know
eight blocks of my house three blocks
from the office and then I wanna Ventura
Boulevard I had to go to the bank and
[ __ ] the positive side I got like
those residual checks from stupid movies
and those pennies are two hours and
fifteen cents
they've been sitting there for a week I
think I had to take a ride right you
like when you just sit now I'm looking
at these three checks between the three
checks they add up to ten bucks okay
it's a 215 but I'm not just gonna throw
them away bro $10 $10 it's a lot of
people need $10 who the [ __ ] am I to
throw away some like every dad do
something different
like you know what's on my list tomorrow
what getting gas like you know when you
have getting gas on your list you know
things a [ __ ] that swim okay so I'm
getting gas tomorrow so I can't make any
plans because they might close the camp
oh I don't want to forget you on your
own Ventura I'm on Ventura
yeah minding my own business right
what's our favorite Chinese rest of us
you know Chinese are chinese a green
apple I'm sorry dog on the corner a guy
totally naked waiver the people tell
these people that neighborhood that's
unlike year that's a nice white
neighborhood cross the street from our
deli it's looking Beverly Hills of the
valley it's like the Beverly Hills of
the valley and there's a naked man on
the corner and nobody's talking to you
just doing yours like the vote for me
way yeah like a nobody's beat but Adam
nobody's existing his existence you
don't see some little stuff like that in
LA everyone's crazy now if something
happened okay guys if I walk out there
like this if I walk out the Tujunga
to hungers right down the corner is a
fire department then there's a health
department that area by the Health
Department guys it's so bad at night so
there's a new hotel across from the
health department that's [ __ ] empty
they built that hotel
like 18 years and they opened it like
March 1st right for Corona
Leora the grand opening was like March
16th they've been empty you going there
right now you get a room for 10 bucks
it's a beautiful little hotel an extra
there's a coffee shop and next one is a
Lutheran Church okay not only learn
about literal people and of course from
the Lutheran Church is a Lutheran School
that belongs to the church it's called
st. Paul's when my wife was looking for
a daycare for mercy my wife went
everywhere but all these people around
here served my goat cheese and [ __ ] take
the kid so my wife didn't want that for
my child you know they were all like
[ __ ] all they eat sushi for lunch or
brown rice mom I said what happened to
[ __ ] apples yeah all very like
menage-a-trois take places you know so
my wife settled on st. Paul's and and my
personal experience with them I loved
them I don't care if they're Lutheran
Jewish Catholic coming over Lutheran is
but the point being I've trusted my
daughter with them for two three years I
think mercy went in there and one and a
half and she got out of there when she
was five she basically family over there
one of the girls sleeps at my house
three nights a week I don't even say it
cleanliness here she comes and after I
go to bed and she wakes up at 6:00 and
leaves takes a shower hopes my wife out
it's great I shall follow as the
principal and then there's another
teacher there that hangs out with my
wife these are the people these are
great American people then white people
but they ain't bothering nobody so this
church is stuck next to this [ __ ]
neighborhood that you know that back
street down where the Buddhist temple is
that a little Ankush in school that Lang
fishing school is where they did the
jacks Tower when Jax teller did when
they did the school shooting and sons of
anarchy
that's the school they use it's it's
behind it's behind that street next to a
karate school behind no
Oh Dinah so all that is that area there
it's really bad one day I saw a guy
laying on his stomach drinking water
from the fire department was washing
their truck he was licking the water
from the floor if you guys know this is
all this is within walking distance of
that train station we were talking about
and the the Greyhound station the grass
and there's a greyhound station that's
horrible
and those people that sit out there it's
closes at six o'clock at night and it
reopens I got four in the morning so
those people just walk around the
[ __ ] neighborhood and they go to
normal diner and no whole diner starving
outside you know no hold I'm is a scary
place oh yeah like when you go in there
2:00 in the morning you better you pray
for your life they don't get robbed cuz
they're close to the 170 I don't like
that place I love yum yum donuts to get
a doughnut but as far as [ __ ] going in
there at night and sitting there and
writing jokes never gonna happen
you know it's right there off the 1-7
did you see something over by the church
too so no so my point is the church is
across the street from how big is the
park bro see football field remember
there's two parts there's no whole part
then there's a park across the street
and they have a library they have tennis
courts there was swimming pool baseball
field a baseball field that's huge a rec
center and then behind they have a
skateboard camp and on Thursdays they do
food trucks and there's hundreds of
people every week they have you know
Lobster trial can [ __ ] Thai food and
for Rican food sometimes they have they
do they really do that Puerto Rican food
I look at every Thursday I used to go to
go we used to go on Thursday nights with
my daughter what the same fall who pull
her out anyway back the same fall so the
lady comes over one night and she's
telling my wife that the school has been
[ __ ] crazy lately wall wearing masks
when the front of the house were outside
and we're talking about st. Paul's and
she's telling us how the school's been
crazy over there lat
that they woke up they opened up the
school and there was a homeless guy in
the school I had to call the cops and
the cops had to come the guy refused to
go and then another guy broke into the
homeless school and they took a [ __ ] and
then they deface the property again if
you've ever seen the episode of Sons of
Anarchy with Gemma
when Jimmy Smits confronts Gemma after
she finds out that she's killed Jax
tellers wife there's gates you'll see it
the first scene that she does when she
calls Jimmy Smits she's at that church
the second scene she's in front of the
day care center feel like him I've seen
Sunday night show you guys have never
seen Sons of Anarchy it's the episode
when Jimmy towards the end it's like
either the last two episodes she shoots
all day then she says goodbye to the kid
the grandson and they shot that scene
across the street at the baseball field
so there's a ton of room that guy's my
point is there's a ton of [ __ ] room
in that area that's it any way you want
so the other day I wake up and my wife
goes do you see what's going on right
now and I don't know what's going on now
another [ __ ] guy got shot or
something what the [ __ ] happened now she
was st. Paul's is on TMZ it's trending
on TMZ because an african-american woman
sent him to one of the trees and then no
trespass that was there I don't see that
yeah did you hear about it I mean yeah
you see that one side of a video yeah
but here's the thing
did you just watch the video yeah you
know like the guy told us you know it
they're like [ __ ] old white people
over there they're not there look at the
problems acting like that I don't think
they explain themselves right like you
don't understand what having a ton of
problems here with people breaking in
and we just don't want anybody on the
property if we feel uncomfortable with
you on our property I actually had
someone pull something on me recently
with this like still it's a very similar
thing my car just got broken into in my
apartment complex that I have at my
apartment complex has like a gate to get
to park in a garage and there's
this big Mexican dude with the truck
pulled up at the front of the gate and
said hey I'm coming to see my grandma
can you open the gate for me I said you
know what ma'am
I'll go grab her for you if you want
we're apartment is she in anyone do it
and I was like he's like I know let me
just come in I'm like now you know what
I'm sorry I can't do that back I'll go
grab her for you
and he said to me he said is it because
I'm Mexican I said I he didn't know that
I broke up a positive no I'm dead a
Mexican girl I just can't let someone
into the apartment and he's he he bag he
gave up and he left I don't think he
actually was seeing someone I know but
it it is it's I it's a really big topic
right now as people get upset
but it doesn't like when people say are
you racists it feels it's like a it's a
kind of an attack like you feeling like
you're being attacked almost well it's
very scary I detainers okay this now
we're seeing what's called agitators and
you Church people is seeing it you guys
are saying they did they're just
agitators they just go out and they go
from Dean Cain and they agitate and they
try to shake people's tree up you know
and it's a shame I know those people at
st. Paul's they did not deserve a
write-up now do you know the back end to
that no then they got protesters there
on a Sunday guess what they did they
invited the men and they invited the
african-american girl to church there to
see what they're all about and now
they're good but they got ripped through
the [ __ ] mud for no reason
I mean yeah there was a reason the girl
took it wrong you know they told the
african-american girl she couldn't sit
then guess what happened the next day I
will know whether the check on there was
a white guy sitting on the lawn just to
see if they would come out and bust
their balls anything so I know so that's
the degree of what's going on right now
yeah that's the degree of what's going
on right now now when you see it on the
news or you see it happening somewhere
else you go wow that could happen guess
what
it's happening here we just went to
level to lack what level wanted to I
think we're back down to level one
because they closed everything
clothes pretty much everything people
are refusing to close we got a we got a
state that's [ __ ] divided he Orange
County was on California la border
Orange County wants to open their
schools with no social distancing and
mass you know listen guys four percent
of people getting coded a kids under ten
you know the percentage is a [ __ ]
wild you know the problem with those
kids is that [ __ ] spreads with those
kids I get both I get both views listen
I don't want my daughter in a home all
[ __ ] day she's got to go to school but
I'm also concerned about the teachers
you know they have families they go to
places you know what the teachers have
to live in isolation too but at the same
time a child can't spend five hours a
day on the computer learning it just
doesn't comprehend it doesn't flow right
they need the socialization they need to
see other kids their age their seven a
thousand times they speak their own
[ __ ] language
I mean you've even had her at home since
it's like four or five months do you see
a difference with her did you see the
difference with the end of the school
year I saw first of all I'm not [ __ ]
doctor the first month March 16th to
April 1st I saw a kid that didn't really
know what was happening
you know she didn't really know what was
happening around there she didn't
understand why she wasn't going to
school you know we had the news on that
night and she would pop out from time to
time and she started asking about
kovaydin and then she you know they're
not stupid they're not stupid they
listen just because she's playing her
fucking's Nintendo switch in the living
room doesn't mean she's not listening to
her 894 that's reported today in [ __ ]
New York City she heard all that then by
April you know we figure we got it down
early we got the process down early you
know I thought my wife was doing like oh
whoa we're doing it wrong
when they go to school in the morning we
take her there at 8:00 but she doesn't
go into the classroom to 8:25 you know
why they do that then let them get their
Yaya's out that first burst the [ __ ]
energy from the cereal you got to assume
they had captain charcoal and they're
ready to strangle a [ __ ] so
that's what I assume in the morning is
that she's ready to strangle the
[ __ ]
which if you see her at 8:15 you know
she's ready to go
so at 8:15 we had to take her outside
and the guys I yeah you know I've been
through hell in my life you don't know
what hell is - you have to keep the kids
occupied that is high energy she's not a
bad child but she's very high energy so
you have to keep her you know she's
smart man and you have to challenge her
mind sometime the time so every day we
had to go we had different parking lots
the parks were closed so we gotta go to
[ __ ] parking lots
we had a wiffle ball bat one day one day
we had tennis with those little [ __ ]
butterflies I asked that we brought hula
hoops you should've seen me a little
hoop and I'm not a good hula hoop you
know what I am whatever hoop days are
over with you know we bought bikes
she had a biker anyway we taught her how
to ride a bike that was good for about
three weeks then that obviously got old
you know you know um kids were hidden we
would take him to the park and it was
still not known what was going on so
there was no kids in our lives and then
we started figuring out the zooming for
them and facetiming so she started
FaceTime with two or three of her
friends and then thank God one of the
mothers is a nurse at a major hospital
and she broke down everything for us she
got us masks I mean this sounds because
I mean I grew up and I feel like I was a
nervous kid do you see her being anxious
or nervous no she'sshe's I'm looking at
her very closely you know I wanted to
stay healthy but kid the kids need kids
and the psychologists I'm gonna dog
I know me and I know how I was at that
age
yeah I had my problems I was young I you
know I at first I was very insecure my
dad had died you know I'm building
models I'm staying and then my mom
pushed me out there and then once she
pushed me out there was no bringing me
back in it like once I discovered the
world and the freedom I had you know my
wife and I were talking last night about
something I know we were talking about
my friend that his daughter walks to the
pizza place New Jersey I know can you
believe that he lets her go to the pizza
place like that's big you know and she
goes by herself she's 12 with her
friends you know and my wife is like
what were you doing at that a I'm like
at 7:00 I'm I'm still walking six
walking 30 blocks
yeah like into Harlem to buy a gun hot
pants by James Brown at Mercy sage
that's an area of a to kids till about
six or seven police would stop you now
yeah and we had beat cops then there
were cops on the [ __ ] beat you know
so ya know what this is so there were
cops on the beat so yeah I didn't know
what to expect but right now this is
just this shutdown is just not working I
mean I know an Arizona I don't know how
you people doing taxes and in Florida I
mean you know we're not gonna recover
from this but two years
yeah there's no recovery all you have to
do is take a ride tomorrow on to Melrose
so you need to do tomorrow at 12:00 take
your little VW bucks there and go over
the [ __ ] hill just go to Joe's pizza
go look down to Melrose down on Crescent
Heights and make a left and come back
home on the 101 and call me and you let
me know what you see the future of Ike
in LA it's not good to calm me students
not coming back for a while
I hear rumblings about the Laugh Factory
rumblings around already about the Laugh
Factory I know the improv will never
close but
they're not opening in the foreseeable
future I mean the only thing that's
caving some of these other places is
like the parking lot shows and we don't
really have a part Hollywood at least
like I said you know I talked to Al on
Joe Bowden yesterday and he said he did
a couple guest sets in La Jolla and it
was great but it was like crack like
exactly what I told you I don't want to
go on stage but I could do it every day
for me to just go I can go on stage
tonight you and I both know there's a
place where you go on stage a couple
people I vote for mics I can go I can go
every that if I wanted to I just can't I
just can't right now
first of all I gotta stay safe there's a
lot those open mics are kind of dirty
they don't you know because they're
trying to hide them the door is closed
so you're in there breathing with
neither ten people so that's not good
right there so you know what when we're
ready for stand-up we'll be ready for
stand-up that's it no big deal I mean
yeah guys I'm mourning a little bit when
you see me now I'm happy I could swear
to you guys there's no depression
there's no nothing I'm [ __ ] happy I'm
okay with this everybody's losing money
I've accepted it life is not about money
it's about being happy I've accepted all
this [ __ ] the comedy part of I'm not
going out at night I'm having a little
hard time with it it's starting to
bother me now
it really is eating away at me a little
bit not enough to hit some in the head
with an axe handle not enough to yell at
my wife none of that [ __ ] like will cool
me and my wife the baby the house is
stronger than ever it's just I don't see
a good future here so now I gotta make
my decisions you know after this
shutdown this shutdown we did not need I
could have gone off summer we could have
gone on all summer how we were doing
with recovery but this shutdown just
destroyed us and let's be honest this
shutdown there's gonna be till November
to the election they're gonna shut us
down to do the main
[ __ ] whatever the mail-in voting or
that's the scam that's a word on the
street so I've accepted nothing I could
do today yesterday morning I got a call
at 9:30 in the morning that my
Philadelphia date October 24th that I
was [ __ ] looking forward cuz you know
I go to the parks casino I get there on
Thursday I do nothing but eat that week
let me taste my same when I go to Philly
I saved my weight watcher bonus points I
live like a skeleton all week until I
get to Philly I head to Philly I got 45
points to kill but the points I got for
the day and I used every [ __ ] one of
them I love Philadelphia all my [ __ ]
heart that breaks my [ __ ] heart
they have canceled live events in
Philadelphia till February of 2021 are
you [ __ ] kidding me how many places
are gonna survive you know helium I love
that guy he's got all those clubs but
that's how's he gonna keep the doors
open too until February you know I mean
this is what's actually going on I just
got a call tonight from a dear friend of
mine about another friend of mine that
struggling and I explained to him that
after this closing our friend cannot
mathematically make it
he cannot mathematically make it in a
business that he does what he's doing
right now is breaking even if they force
him to close again he hasn't paid rent
in three months this is all and the
rents gotta be all paid in full by
September 1 all right mathematically he
cannot do it what he could do is cut a
deal with the landlord make payments so
it doesn't turn into a judgment so
nobody goes to court and move on with
his life
I mean the sadness I have is that think
of how many people have to close their
business look at each other and go is
this worse the hemorrhage we worked for
30 [ __ ] years to get to where we are
and we can either stay open because we
have loyal employees or we could give
our employees or loyal
little check and closed this
[ __ ] out and you know already
you've read the people that have closed
in Hollywood already you've read the
punkin places sixty-year-old place all
over the country that's all the news
everywhere and I think both sides are
our fault but to me it's it's like the
saddest part about this is it shows how
divided I think a lot of people are
because if we if we all as a country
agree to shut down for two three weeks
this would be over but because I some
places are different than other places
it's gonna be I think it's gonna go on
for four years I see it once I mean when
you go on mint or a Boulevard you don't
see you see it you see it a little bit
but you don't feel the gloom you do as
much as when you go to Hollywood this is
what I'm trying to say I'm sorry about
you know telling you our but listen guys
they can't all be [ __ ] hilarity
Podcast some of them have to be realism
we have to be real with one another I
told you guys March 16th that this was
gonna give people time to think well
this [ __ ] lockout this next one this
last one the one that got issued Tuesday
yesterday this one broke me well part of
it
well what about my daughter's not gonna
be able to go to school
we got camped on August 12th if they
shut the whole city down then we have no
camp and basically we're only living
here to do a podcast there's no film
there's no TV not that that's what I'm
interested in at all at all my interest
in that but uh I just see that we have
to make a move I don't know where it's
between Telluride Austin Texas I mean
I've been thinking about a lot of places
I have a dear dear friends and Ari
Colorado and Gunnison and it's [ __ ]
beautiful on the western slope
but Colorado's only gonna go to school
in September to teach their kids how to
[ __ ] do homeschooling so that's the
[ __ ] situation I got listen sometimes
you guys got to hear my [ __ ] problems
too alright it's not all about you
[ __ ] okay I come on here I'd love
with my heart out fees sometimes I gotta
tell you what's going on here
just so you know the real fact about
[ __ ] what's going on here in
California how are you feeling
I thought the King condom today she's in
Florida you know she said she did a
couple gigs it was nice to talk to her
you know that's not one of the saddest
things for me because I she was thinking
of coming back here she called me I
we've been playing phone tag and I
called her and then today she picked up
and she goes I want to know if you think
it's worth it for me to come back to act
over November I don't think nothing's
gonna be here for you I think your wave
New York like you know word on the
street is the numbers are taking backup
in New Jersey I don't know about New
York I haven't heard New York I heard
it's clean up in northern New York
they're gonna open up a few schools and
they're gonna try or something I don't
really know I don't really know what's
going on I know that if I go to New York
I'm quarantined for two weeks they had
you know so as soon as you get there you
can't leave for two weeks
no you're gonna you can't anywhere from
Arizona Texas to Florida when you go to
New York you got you got a quarantine
yourselfer - wow that's good I mean
that's what I mean that's what we were
talking about was Rogan about about
Jimmy and in Korea it's like if these
places that take it seriously and
quarantine you that's a bug you saw do
you see the NBA player who got in
trouble had to go back in the quarantine
because you got takeout food no we got
to get food delivery on the bubble
listen like try to tell you guys that
that bubble for basketball that's gonna
be very rough on that's gonna be very
very rough on them but that's what we
need my heart Koza
no no no no we need we need sports to
help the economy we need sports
entertainers I mean obviously they're
not shooting anything new they haven't
figured it out but at the same time you
want safety
yeah okay you're putting a bunch of
millionaires in a bubble and I think
their families are with them or whether
they want in there with them but besides
that they're in a bubble remember it's a
lot different me traveling with you and
playing with you than me traveling with
you playing with you and living with you
that creates a different type of
environment I don't know how many weeks
it's gonna be I think after four months
it's gonna be very [ __ ] tough so you
mean to tell me I don't know how many
teams are in this bubble you mean to
tell me as a smart American that Zion
Williamson the rookie sensation and I
hate to put it this way but I have to
just so you people understand where I'm
coming from
you don't look me in the eye and tell me
that Zion whatever city isn't gonna
sneak out to get his dick sucked it's
hard that's what you telling me that one
of those NBA players doesn't have a
dirty white chick waiting for him in
Orlando cuz that's a home of dirty white
chicks though and that's a capital
hundred dirty white chicks looking
sloppy they know all it's busy NBA's
there yeah then watch me [ __ ] there
so think about it I'm not trying to be a
wiseass I'm gonna try to crack stupid
jokes I'm just trying to be a
phonological perspective here do you
really think these guys are gonna stay
in there every night
have you played sports have you ever
traveled with that sports team the first
thing you want to do as a kid is sneak
out when I played mini basketball all
that [ __ ] I heard stories and [ __ ]
those guys sneaking out and buying beers
and getting caught and putting sleeping
pills and the coaches milk and you know
this is what you did you snuck out
you're a kid how am I not gonna have a
good time in the hotel room this is what
you do so you mean to tell me I don't
know how many teams are there but each
one of these guys is gonna play
basketball staying and that's all they
have to do is bat me night we would love
to do them we do that's it they built
amusements for them in there there's
[ __ ] for them to do in there so they're
not bored I mean we've all been
homes for the last four months how
[ __ ] bored are you they start
organizing how [ __ ] bored of most of
you people that [ __ ] working from
your house living at your house getting
food delivered the house
how [ __ ] bored are you at one point
of the day do you actually feel like
crying sometimes for me at seven o'clock
every night at seven o'clock I want to
shut it to it as soon as I hear the
first key that thun thun thun jeopardy I
just want to [ __ ] put my hands
between my head and hold them and cry
but I don't I don't I look up and I go
you know what we're gonna work this
thing through you know I I feel I feel
terrible for America right now there's
people will really [ __ ] struggling I
know somebody who had a nervous
breakdown last week gotta go to the
hospital I'm the great lady dear friend
of mine it's just too much it's
overwhelming another friend of mine his
mother-in-law had so much anxiety that
she dehydrated something happens to your
whatever levels of something they had a
Russia to the hospital they got like an
IV because you're whatever Gatorade
[ __ ] supplies like joins electrolytes
something was off in her body so you
know I mean this is what's going on with
people people are drinking more than
ever
well like that's why it's interesting
you talking about the kid earlier I'm
very lucky that a lonely person I have
to worry about is myself I can't imagine
having the stress of of just me and then
not only do I have to worry about my kid
by at the teacher to I have to have to
be nom nom in school like oh I don't
mind I had to read a bunch of [ __ ] and
reacquaintance my son mean dog dog
there's parents right now got a banging
their heads on a wall America there are
parents right now that are banging their
heads on the walkers who's gonna
watch these kids you got three kids you
work and I work
how we gonna [ __ ] do this so my heart
goes out to those people there are
parents right now they're going holy
[ __ ] if my kid doesn't go back to school
and that's the aim and I was talking
about some stuff earlier but the other
side of it is how sad how sad is it that
we we can't trust our government I'm not
saying that this is a whole fake or hoax
but there's a there's at least a chance
that this is fake but it's not that's
how crazy and you want to say that I
grew up trusting like I grew up trusting
the president the the police the fact
like we lose at least a inkling that we
can't trust what they're telling us well
America is at a crossroads right now you
know America's were a crossroads at the
police America's grow crossroads with
African Americans Americans in a
crossroads the Latinos when a crossroads
right now in this crossroad could leave
to a civil war you know seems like
there's a lot of african-american hate
crime now on other people the videos
have been posted
you know people feel unsafe uncertain
you know when why it's gonna be scary is
because why I got scary as a human being
when my heart turned black that's when I
used to steal when my mother died I
thought the world turned on me and the
government turned on me they wanted
paperwork for me to get money that was
supposed to come to me from my father
and my mother so all those things broke
down so I'm reliving it I'm saying
people go through what I went through at
16 losing their job losing him mother
losing a wife losing a child
losing your job that you've been doing
for 20 years people cameramen directors
ADEs you know all those people people
who went to school for editing and been
out here editing for 20 years not
shooting nothing right now right now
this sitting at home tiddlywink it you
know yeah what about the kids on the
other hand who just
to a college what about those kids and
those didn't think I what about not
having a graduation you know all these
things are weighing on people yeah so
yes your nan trust in the government
your confusion in the morning of the
death of your not having a job you know
two weeks you lose your benefits I mean
I hate to be [ __ ] Joey downer but yes
this weighs on people the reason why we
do the podcast is so you understand that
you're not the only one I'm telling you
guys you're not the only one so please
listen like I said it once I live by
these things you never see a bookie but
a part-time job and there's no debtors
prison there was a time when I thought
my world was over and it was just
starting it was just starting and it was
29 years ago tomorrow so 29 years ago
tomorrow I started calmly you know I did
something that I never thought I would
do it was a changing of the guard it was
uh I was at the crossroads I had a job
that paid me well good money I had a
truck I had a [ __ ] cell phone I had a
cool cush job I could you know you know
me I still work woke up at 6:00 and did
the whole thing but if I was a regular
guy could get there at 11:00 measure
some roofs not me I got up at 6:00 and
went down in help with the roof and the
supplies and I went and did my beds and
all this [ __ ] I had it but I'd when
there thought about it I'm like this is
it this is it I'm 65 and they give me a
gold watch for being the estimator of
the year this is what I live for
this is what my mother for there's got
to be more there's got to be more twenty
nine years ago yesterday this is where I
was right now is probably biting my
fingers right now thinking about stand
up I was gonna [ __ ] fail oh this is
gonna be embarrassing who the [ __ ] was I
I had the worst thoughts going through
my head which are the same thoughts I'm
I got going through my head when I get
on stage now who the [ __ ] do I think I
am I'm a bum
why am I even going down there and I got
a laugh at me and I cut off that [ __ ]
stage and the owner of the club said
great job you had great stage presence
and people spoke to me and next thing
you know people were shaking my hand I
was talking to different people and I
felt like [ __ ] caring at the wedding
at the good father's wedding remember
she was overwhelmed there were so many
Peters and paulie's in the room yeah
they know what the [ __ ] was going on you
know I mean the next thing you know I'm
driving home with this woman who was my
wife at the time and I'm thinking how am
I gonna do this for a living
how am I gonna do this for a living 29
years ago tomorrow lat 29 years ago
right now I would probably bite my
[ __ ] nails pissing my [ __ ] pants
crying like a [ __ ] guys can you believe
that that on this night 29 years ago I
was by wish I could actually remember
what I was doing but if you know
anything about me
I was probably having beginning of
anxiety I was I didn't think I was doing
coke when I got into comedy I really
took it seriously I did coke much later
once once my wife left there was no
reason not for the Culkin's and now I
got the whole house to myself I could
crawl I could play John Rambo I could
look out windows but when I got into
comedy I was pretty serious I think I
was just smoking dope because I just
gotten off pissing in a bottle and
something happened like I was like you
know what if I had picked up all this
responsibility at work so I was getting
on holic maybe once a week
it wasn't like so I was still focused
you know the baby was I had a baby
daughter at the time she was a year and
a half I'm like what the [ __ ] am I gonna
do I thought I was just gonna go down
there and get on stage and go home
that's what I really thought that they
were gonna boo me I was gonna get hit
with a tomato and I was gonna go back to
roof in the next day and I got off that
stage and [ __ ]
you know I think for two hours I just
sat there with my mouth open and my body
felt like I had never felt before no
drug could ever match that feeling after
I got on stage the first time well to me
it sounds like a lot like what you're
talking about
is happening now happen to you a few
years from this point when you got
kicked out of Denver and you had didn't
make the choice to leave your all of
your opportunity was taken from me I got
whoa no I I still had here's the thing
listen guys nobody should ever give you
an invite to leave if you're smart
enough you read it and you go you know
how the situation that I know how to get
rid of something in December and I woke
up January 21st and I got rid of that
person I love that person daily but I
just couldn't work with them anymore I
had to get rid of him and I knew her for
a while what was your question just
about her how it's similar now to when
he loved Denver what I love Denver I had
I got thrown out of the comedy works but
I still had McKelvey's I still had wit's
end and Tribble had to run that and
Jimmy Abeyta had four or five rooms have
paid and the other guy had two or three
weeks of paid work I had worked at I
can't say I had tons of work that I had
worked in but again even then I was
letting god control my life without
knowing I let it follow I mean I went to
[ __ ] Michigan to do like in May of
Memorial Day weekend I drove to Michigan
to do my first feature spot at a club
like it was like a coal MEMC spot like I
opened up the showbread the 20 minutes
right and I did well I was really in
shock and I met a girl and she came back
so in the process it in 95 95 wasn't a
good year for me it I was in a position
where I was spending my wheels
I was doing great work as a comic as a
comic I was doing great [ __ ] work but
everything else in my life was [ __ ] I
was waiting around for receipts outside
Kmart you know what the [ __ ] is that
what the what type of human being does
that you know I was just returning [ __ ]
I was you know I would sell drugs I
would sell valium then I had a valium
guy that worked in lincoln-mercury you
were given to me by the thousand like a
thousand volumes 25 cents I would sell
them for $2 the profit margin was
phenomenal phenomenal I always had
pocket money when you sell ten values
who [ __ ] whatever 20 bucks and yet
they cost you two are you [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's pretty crazy 250 and I
made 1750 or something like that so I
would show that that was my little spare
change and I'm doing [ __ ] comic you
know that was my life and the only
reason I was in Boulder was for one
thing to be a father and they didn't
want me to be her father didn't want me
to be a father and on the other end I
didn't deserve to be a father so I
planned it out I met that girl she came
and got me she stayed with me for a week
in Boulder and then she went to Seattle
and I loved to Seattle maybe a week and
a half later I never looked back once he
offered once he offered to go did any
part of you hold back or
yeah sure held back I had a daughter
that I had roots there had been there
for 12 years I did in my time I was
there for 12 years well I wasn't Boulder
food I was involved of 90 I was in
Boulder from 86 to 95 but I was in
Colorado total from 83 to 95 12 years
I was Balder from 86 I hit Balder
November of 86 has a long time I'm sure
I struggle with that with uh decision
like that uh if someone told me hey it's
time to leave
yeah I like that but if I if it's
something that I have to make it to my
decision I go back and forth alliances
between mama died in the fourth war I
knew it was time to leave in May and it
was time to leave I had a funny feeling
I did not know about the devil kind of
reclose I didn't know anything about
that but I thought it was time to leave
in May oh you mean la yeah I'm a I was
already telling people I talked to Rick
Ramos into it he got the [ __ ] out of
here I talked to my other friend to it
he got the [ __ ] out it made sense they
called me and I told him he got a cup I
understand your pain I understand what
you're going through and I wouldn't be
here can you imagine how many people
would have left if they knew it was
gonna last this long like in March you
knew it was gonna last all year I've had
20 20 percent more people leave but I
got the call from Rogan last week that
he's leaving next month that really just
acquainted for me that that's it
it's time to look around and say wow I
pay 13.8% in tax the police is getting
the funded the prisoners are getting now
and crime is on the rise and they have a
daughter Mouse and there's people
walking around looking for a problem
have you ever taken a ride at night
lately no take a ride 11 o'clock at
night go to Lancashire and make a lap
and go up towards victory with you get
the victory what do you see up there oh
and Michael Jim it's it's demolished up
there there's nothing up there Jim they
built the mall the mall to the right but
they were building that farm that's
where the first Karen threw a fit
yeah Joe's right there that's where the
first Karen one and then sand don't [ __ ]
yourself I am breathing problems
yeah but but I mean on the Main Street
actually on Laurel Canyon like there
used to be a couple empty businesses
couple open businesses now there's just
blocks of empty guys
it's [ __ ] listen there was a Thai
store that called 420 do you know I
wanted a date to 420 in 1997 with a girl
up here then live the pant Wow I went to
one date with her and we met there for a
piece of pie and coffee nothing happened
we just met to talk hot goals were
different than mine
and I still remember going in 1997
coming up from Hollywood making the
u-turn parking in there go Wow getting
like a piece of Dutch apple pie not
giving a [ __ ] with ice cream and
definitely just having a Chinese buffet
and so when I moved to the valley I
would take my wife there for breakfast
they had an OK breakfast but then we get
the pie oh yeah and the James pregnant
I'm gaining weight by the [ __ ] day to
see frightening I'm getting to be a fat
[ __ ] so I stopped going in there but one
day my daughter said to me
my wife said to me you know 420 is going
out of business in Van Nuys they had one
on Van Nuys and I was like that's
[ __ ] crazy cuz they have all those
car dealers right how could they go out
of business but listen once you like
that and that's where it is oh wow
that's where it is but then there's a
420 on Laurel Canyon yeah across from
Gelson's so my daughter and I were
talking and she goes dad I can go for a
piece of pumpkin pie after the podcast
I'll take you for a piece of pumpkin pie
let's go support local businesses so we
put our masks on we went in there we
went in there we go come we got a piece
of pumpkin pie God looked me straight in
the face and he goes we got apple we got
just cherry and we got cheesecake we're
closing on Sundays and I'm like what I
could just give me two pieces of
whatever from my wife both of them
didn't like the pie like it was time was
just made with don't work any other
Friday they were just putting the last
two this
there and they closed and they wrote an
article about it I don't know how many
years they were there but you have to
look at this as a human being so uh yeah
we're starting to look we'll still keep
doing the podcast I don't know if we you
want to move to whatever destination I
had to choose I hope he does this is
gonna be very hard here the next two
years uh you know as we have seen rents
are not really dropping you know all I
know New York has a rent moratorium
going in July 31st and people getting
evicted I'm sure a lot of people gonna
get evicted here but what's even the
point you're saying with your friend the
rents due in September still like just
that's the only thing that I think is
positive about this is that there's no
there's nothing to be ashamed about if
stuff goes badly go I told you I told
the dear friend of mine yesterday he
knows he has to close his business Sean
went over there to visit him he was
outside and I spoke to him I looked him
in the face like I want you to know
something I want you to know that you're
a good good guy I want you to know that
you provide a great service you've done
a lot of great things here now this is
out of your control so if anybody's
going through this stuff listening to
this podcast remember these words you
were not God you are not Jesus you're
not Buddha you're not any higher power
everybody's going through something
right now and don't be shameful if you
have to move back with your mom don't be
ashamed if you have to move into your
[ __ ] car don't be ashamed to ask for
help
not right now not right now listen guys
I'm gonna make your confession to you
guys that I don't talk about in this
podcast The Comedy Store I don't even
know why I'm telling you this but I just
want you to know
what's going on in my world for the last
three years a Comedy Store I was doing
random shows you know that and because I
sell tickets they would pay me good
money and they would give me cash
so Tuesdays Wednesdays and Thursdays was
nice guys you know I got paid 15 bucks
for 20 years I deserved the raise okay
let's put it that way for [ __ ]
eighteen years I got $15 just like Joe
Rogan just like Paul Mooney just like
everybody else just like Richard Pryor
just like Bobby Lee
just like the Obon just like Bill burr
but when you did the main room they paid
you and they paid your cash and they
gave me some good money no I did
something I would take that cash because
I'm not ashamed to tell you guys I would
take that cash and I'll put it in the
safe never counted it and then I do
another scam I skim from myself on the
road you know me dog I'm the only guy
that can rob himself okay you jug
yourself a big I charge myself a Vegas
that's supposed to give me money for a
plane ticket I always make them give me
500 bucks cash and yardsticks they're
like why I don't know and then I get
home and nobody knows nothing because
that's part of my plane money you're
following the same thing so I take that
five on the house I open the safe but I
put it in there I don't even have the
safe no more I got rid of it because I'm
right somebody's gonna break it and
think the same okay so I didn't I'll
tell you why I got rid of this safe
first of all I had nothing else in there
I haven't got in there that's it I took
it out now because now you gotta protect
yourself so but I'm gonna be honest with
you guys
for three years every Tuesday and
Thursday I won for the commies throwing
the game in cash I would go home and
throw on that at all never never counted
it
didn't want to count it I said I'm gonna
save this for a rainy day
something's going to happen for a rainy
day then I can't put whatever they was
300 500 you know 750 whatever they would
give me and this is the first time I'm
able to discuss money with you guys I
would put in this mo Kovac came along
one day I said somebody called me and
said they were having a hard time before
like all the two weeks before Kovac a
dear friend of mine I said I got you
covered
what's the amount that you need and they
told me it was it wasn't a lot of money
but you know it was money I go no
problem I mean he was a childhood friend
of mine he bailed me out of thirteen
million [ __ ] things and he's
struggling now I want to repay the favor
so I went into the envelope and I was
gonna give my wife it's the cash to
deposit it to write him a check so it
wouldn't come out of the house you know
my wife wouldn't say you know that's
house money you give it to your friends
I took that money and I counted it I
don't want to tell you how much money
was in that envelope well I'd say it was
twenty grand in cash plus Wow because it
was three years and filmed that envelope
every week would gladly store money okay
and there were all hundred dollar bills
Vegas do you know what what there's not
a hundred out the left remember I gave
five thousand to the store I took that
money and I sent it out to my friends
who I knew wouldn't need it I didn't
want them to ask me I never you never
let a friend embarrass themselves and
they're going through help so before
they could even ask I just put it in my
[ __ ] PayPal account and sent it out
without even asking they called and said
Joey
we don't want the money but you're not
gonna believe this we didn't even know
how we're gonna pay our shop this month
one friend of mine called me cuz I don't
even know how well pay my shop and I
figured that was mine that's how I can
help during this time you know I think I
did a couple of hundred for a cat
shelter and I donated money from the
church to the men North Hollywood
whatever I went over there dropped off
clothes and gave us week bills cash I
dropped off all my sweatpants my big fat
man sweatpants and [ __ ] I had 20 hooded
sweatshirts I just put him in a bag when
they had that homeless thing up here in
North Hollywood and I went up there
chopped off and I gave the lady 300 cash
that was laughing that money that's it I
don't not mad that's what that money was
for a rainy [ __ ] day but it was I
thought it was gonna be for me and they
loved being for my friends and that's
what you live life for that's it
granted I'm sure everyone pees some
money but selfishly this doesn't feel a
little bit did it feel good to have
people be that like happy like I know
you know that's not why you did it but
when you make someone that happy it has
to make you feel good zombie steaks Joe
Rogan bought me the only TV shows senex
the entertainer put me in do you have
any idea how may times Ralphie made took
care of me who was here last week Josh
wolf levitated time he took me to buy
three pair of suits for our TV show you
know I think Brody gave me a couple
hundred one time to eat this would
happen it's brother
you can't ask back you can't ask it back
Josh wolf never asked back with the
money for the suits you know you know
many times I just had the balls -
rolling 400 bucks
and he would give it to me without
blinking an eye knowing it was for drugs
but what can he do he didn't want me to
rob somebody or something like that so I
don't know I mean I've had very good
friends that have been very good to me
how can I deny and these are kids from
Jersey these are all kids there was a
couple waitresses you know but these
were kids from Jersey that you know they
go back to the sixth grade one day I
asked everybody I asked a couple friends
and they said they were all right
but I knew I and for them that weren't
all right I had one friend that was
moving into a new place I knew he needed
to deposit right before he asked I just
sent him a [ __ ] certified check you
know he doesn't have PayPal this is what
this life is about it's remembering you
know especially in times like this I
wish I could do more I wish I wish I was
Bill Gates and I get do more and I could
just you know but I'm not you know I
could just do what I could do so this is
a time right now that your bank account
means nothing because there's somebody
missing a [ __ ] meal the truth it's
the [ __ ] truth
you know laughs I did I joined the bunch
I subscribed to a bunch of people's
pantry outs nice I took some money I'm
not gonna tell you some dirty girls I
bought their holy fans I wanted cause I
want to look but the reason why I did it
was because I want to look at what
people are putting out there
what I'm doing is supporting an opinion
in a painter tomorrow is my 29th
anniversary and comi I've been doing a
podcast with you guys three years I
Instagram with you guys for years my
periscope with you guys for years and I
got a new idea I want to do a show
called to mind the Joey Diaz and I'm
gonna tell you some stuff you don't know
some stuff you're not gonna know
we'll put it on patreon it's gonna be
patreon.com slash Joey Diaz it's a a
couple videos a week some inspirational
stuff some vlogs I'm gonna write some
blogs in there also and the beauty of it
is it's a dollar you want to give to
lollies give to Lau's I don't give a
[ __ ] you want to judge me
give me five dollars I don't know what
I'm doing is this my guy that shoots the
videos he's not working he's a director
I wish I could pay him from the church
money but as you guys see even I had to
down so I'm gonna have him use videos
you know my friend Mike
Klein does all the posters and he puts
up wall of videos and he's at a peak
also where he doesn't think he's going
back to work so what I'm trying to do
with this dollar is spread it around
this is gonna be the mind that Joey Diaz
it's a magazine it's a patreon account
it's got nothing to do with the podcast
podcast is still gonna come on Mondays
and Wednesdays I'm not [ __ ] with the
podcast is this is to see you guys all
day long it's a job patreon.com slash
Joey Diaz
this helps to three people doesn't make
them rich but it helps them out and
we're gonna take a little bit every
month and donate to a cat saying my wife
is looking for a legitimate cat thing to
put up on the one the patreon I'm gonna
give you inspirational things in the
morning because they have a 15-second
video I loved I loved it so I can just
go on there and call you [ __ ]
[ __ ] son of a [ __ ] I've already
I've been practicing on a fake site that
my manager made me for the last weekend
they [ __ ] love that they came over
and they're like this is they're gonna
go crazy so it probably goes live
sometime Friday you know we do an
Instagram Friday night 7:00 p.m. you
around you go to Vegas this week longer
and he fights this weekend I think so
yeah okay good someone do blue will be
back Friday night we'll do a little
Instagram live at 7 o'clock at night
just let's smoke a joint you know what
the [ __ ] you're staying again and just
say yeah house and wine are manly but
yeah but this would be an interesting
idea I don't have a day job no more guys
I don't have a night job no more I'm not
looking for a handout I'm looking to be
held to something I'm looking for
somebody to hold me to my commitment and
the only way I could do that is I can't
charge you firehouse I'm not gonna
charge you $10 I'm not worth that kind
of money but that's why I got a couple
people's patreon to support them and to
see what they were doing and I got some
Dirty Birds to help them out you know
just to see what the [ __ ] they're doing
those disgusting pages then just
disgusting
I haven't seen yeah it's just you know I
was thinking of doing it only France and
they're a great service they provide a
great thing but my manager was tighter
with the dude from patreon so we talked
to him he thought it was a good idea and
when I told him I just wanted out that's
it
listen the social networks now Twitter
and Facebook you know what bro
guys they get a little bit too crazy
they got a little bit too crazy tonight
some guy wrote on there when you wake
that girl's [ __ ] he robbed the girl I
never said no way I robbed the girl we
brought a boyfriend we robbed the guy
she was working for people are taking
everything the wrong way whether it's
whether you say something funny
whether you say something I don't you
don't be I don't post politically and
nothing like that I just tell you to go
like I farted today I showed you picture
me on the bike with the helmet did you
see that yeah the nice little red helmet
just to let you know I got problems too
I got problems just like everybody else
I put a little red helmet on this [ __ ]
like a Momo
I got my little facemask out there ride
the bike 50 [ __ ] two minutes I almost
got hit twice today
it's crazy out there yeah it's crazy
I go to that park and I just do circles
around the loop like all the way to
Laurel Canyon pass the cold water I just
go on all the side streets and it's
great I do it at 9:30 in the morning
my anxiety [ __ ] goes away cuz when I
got up I got to do something so when my
wife takes the baby the [ __ ] camp
boom I bust on that [ __ ] bike no iPod
no hearing aids no nothing it's just me
and [ __ ] nature out there and I'm
loving it
you know I'm trimming down a little bit
I'm feeling better and it's because of
you guys what we've been doing here so
again it's patreon.com slash Joey Diaz a
dollar a dollar that's it if next month
you want to get $2 you give $2 it's a
dollar for [ __ ] quarters you
understand me for [ __ ] cordless
patreon.com slash Joey Diaz that's it
nice and easy I just want to check in
with you guys and let you know we're all
going through [ __ ] we're going through
[ __ ] [ __ ] it no we're not Kim Kardashian
what I loved and I would Kanye West with
a waitress serving this [ __ ] shrimp
we're dying down here too we're with you
guys man so you know I love you
[ __ ] all my heart but first
listen the Church of what's happening
now is also brought to you by Express V
P and right now all living our lives on
the Internet your kids got school on the
iPad your wife's got the in-laws on
FaceTime you're trying to watch porn you
know now more than ever you need to
protect your privacy you don't want
people to know you're watching black
midgets jump up and down and they're
[ __ ] out a little african-american
midgets you don't want nobody to see
that dude so I hate to break it to you
you know why not use a private code
because it doesn't work on suckers no
matter how many times you erase your
history people can still see every site
you've ever visited that's not a good
[ __ ] thing for me it is I don't give
a [ __ ] I don't know the bad sites how
about the underworld but we'll
expressvpn I do online it's nobody's
business okay the way it works
started going directly from your house
to the internet everything I do online
goes to expressvpn secure service
it's a putting the rubber on before you
bang the internet and you're anonymous
you get an IP address that cannot be
tracked your info is secure expressvpn
encrypts a hundred percent a hundred
percent of your personal data and it
works for every person and device in
your home again it works for every
person and device in your home it's easy
as pie to use even for a [ __ ] Momo
like me just push one button seamless
right listen if you think putting your
browser on private will keep the
Russians from knowing what the [ __ ] you
jerk off to you're slipping [ __ ]
so do me a favor to protect your online
activity today go to VPN I trust them to
secure my privacy my wife uses it right
now the Church of what's happened now
family go to expressvpn dot-com
slash Church CH you are CH to get three
extra months free on your one-year
subscription that's Express VPN dot-com
slash Church again support the podcast
and protect yourself guys because people
are rummaging through [ __ ] right now go
to expressvpn right when you listen to
this podcast com slash Church I'm gonna
get you three free months on a year so
that means you pay for my months I'm
getting you a deal
alright expressvpn I want to thank them
I want to thank on it but most
importantly I want to thank you guys
like I said you're gonna be really
surprised with this mind the Joey Diaz
I'm gonna blow your mind right from the
[ __ ] jump so we get ready to get your
mind blown and if not I'll see you next
time I say I'll give you a [ __ ]
dollar right I love you guys search
what's happening now we'll be back
Monday more than talk about cat tarot
cards kick this [ __ ] meal whoo let's
get the [ __ ] out of here
[Music]